the fried liver attack one of my
favorite attacks because I'm making the
list I get to put some pretty aggressive
openings in here and since I'm a pretty
aggressive player the fried Li attack is
obviously going to make my list if
you're not too familiar Pawn 2 E4 Pawn
E5 Knight F3 Knight C6 Bishop to C4 and
then after Knight to F6 White's going to
bring his Knight up here to G5 attacking
with his bishop and his Knights here on
G5 to F7 and then if opponent decides to
go ahead and try to stop that with Pawn
here to D5 we're going to play Pawn
capturing after the Knight captures then
this Knight's going to sacrifice here on
F7 so if you like to sacrifice this is
definitely going to be one of your go-to
openings because it's just really fun
who doesn't want their opponent to bring
out their King and then they bring their
Queen involved and they just chase their
opponents pieces all over the board so
definitely definitely one of my top 10
openings